Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's time for the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
September 28th,
2015 what's going on in Iowa?
Yeah.
How's it going?
Oh yeah.
Fucking burned out.
Uh,
just got back from the road.
Ah,
what a tour I had.
What a lovely,
wonderful time I had going all the way through Texas.
I want to thank everybody who came out to the shows this week.
Uh,
we had an awesome time.
Probably too much fun,
if you know what I mean.
Um,
and when I say that,
I mean I'm on my way back.
The pendulum's swinging back the other way for me to become a fat pasty titty
jackass again.
However,
I am a,
I'm going to nip it in the A,
is it in the bud?
Is it in the bud?
You know,
nipping something in the button like a dog bite somebody in the ass.
So you are,
you're pruning a fucking flower.
I have no idea.
But what I do know is that I'll get a hundred emails telling me how fucking dumb
I am.
Um,
but getting a bunch of those lately.
Jesus Christ to fucking critics out there.
Yeah,
mother fuckers.
It just,
I'm just taking it,
just taking my God damn knees out lately,
you know?
Did I ever say I was smart?
I don't think I did.
I don't know.
I don't know what their problem is.
Oh,
I know what their problem is.
Yeah.
They probably didn't go after what they wanted in life and now they're fucking
miserable.
So they just sit around on me,
Eh,
dino,
some jerk off,
send me an email.
He actually counted how many times me and Paul verse.
He said,
dude,
it was one of the saddest things I ever heard.
Why the fuck would you like counted over a hundred times?
That's what she did.
That's what she did with a half hour.
Your Life.
You fucking dope.
Some people,
you just want to fucking shaken by this shoulders.
Good Lord.
Turn it off then I do an apologize for the levels,
man.
I know.
I fucked it up last time.
Uh,
you know,
it's this weird thing where the levels can be completely way too high,
but if in the headphones you don't hear it,
you know,
that's what you have in mixer for.
It's actually what you have a sound guy for.
And I don't have one.
Um,
so I apologize for that.
but I think it was very fitting that the podcast on Thursday in an audio sense
was completely fucked up.
And for some of you in a verbal sense,
um,
anyways,
I think,
uh,
you know,
if you saw the fucking abuse that we did last week to our bodies,
I don't know what my fucking problem is that we,
I couldn't fucking stop,
couldn't stop.
Like every night I would be dragging ass,
getting ready to go do my show,
going through what the fuck am I doing?
Then the second he'd go out on stage,
the adrenaline starts going and you get a couple laughs,
you feel fucking great,
right?
And then literally the first show,
halfway through it,
I'll just be thinking like,
Hey,
I can have a beer tonight.
I have one,
I'll have one.
Then I'll go to bed.
And it'll be fine.
And next thing you know,
you walk in the streets of San Antonio and the fucking security guard at the
Alamo tells you to get the fuck out of there.
You know,
it's versus running around.
Mercy goes,
take a picture of me in front of the Alamo,
right?
And I,
you got to know that right now.
How fucking drunk we are walking around like a couple of dopes with smoking
cigars of course.
Right?
And let's go,
let's go home and smoke a cigar in front of the fucking Alamo.
You know,
why not do that?
Why,
why learn about the history?
Um,
we actually ended up learning about the history cause for,
he went over and he goes,
don't take a picture of me in front of the Alamo.
And for some reason as this security guard working late night,
he goes,
hey,
you can't do that.
You can't do that.
Silversea goes,
take the picture and he rips his shirt off and makes this absolutely psycho look
on his face just to get the fucking security guard going.
Say,
what do you mean we can't do that?
Why can't we can't take a picture of the fucking Alamo,
is it after hours?
So then he comes up when he thinks we're a couple of drunk assholes,
which we are right?
You got to see the picture of Rosie.
I sent it to him.
Maybe he'll put it online.
I'm going to leave it up to him.
But dude,
I have to tell you,
Paul versus these,
one of the most happiest go lucky people I've ever seen in my life.
And he looks like a fucking serial killer.
Like I saw the photo and I said to him,
I was like,
dude,
if this picture was was the poster of a movie,
I would go see it immediately.
You look like a fucking lunatic.
Um,
so anyways,
the guy comes over and he starts talking to us and immediately we just started
asking them questions about the alimony.
He couldn't resist,
he couldn't resist.
And he started telling us all this information and I was sitting there going,
well,
like,
no wonder all the guys died.
Look how small the Wallace,
that's like even smaller than that thing that people have to run up on.
And a at the end of the American Ninja Warrior,
you know,
if anything would fuck me over on that show,
as long as you had a decent halfway decent thing,
you could figure,
you could work the grip strength up.
Right,
right.
If they had like a approaching 50 years old American Ninja Warrior obstacle
course,
I feel like I could work my way up to get through it,
but there's nothing helping.
There's nothing helping my phone.
I got white guy disease.
You know what I mean?
White guys,
we got those meaty calves.
They weigh us down.
You know what I mean?
We need those fucking deer legs.
We just don't have,
we got big dumb meaty calves.
Our calves are like fucking like ankle weights.
I don't know what it is,
but there's no fucking way I could ever get over that.
So I'm sitting there looking at the wall at the Alamo going like,
dude,
I swear to God.
I feel like I could do a run plant one foot midway up the wall and I think I got
a shot.
I got a shot,
man.
I could go right up and over.
What's up.
They had Dan,
you'll bone.
What do you say to his Sam Houston was Davy Crockett.
Huh?
What about that guy who settled Virginia and Bang,
the Indian woman and then they shaved his head and they made him one of them,
right?
Then they murdered everybody but him.
What was his name?
What was it?
Eddie.
Virginia.
I know it has something to do with Virginia.
Tim Richmond,
the fuck was his name.
Michael West Virginia.
Um,
Jones town.
What the fuck was that guy's day?
But we'll do the first settlement down there in Virginia.
I know there's the city of,
there's a street named after him,
isn't there?
That guy fucking did it.
Right?
Right.
He landed there and immediately interacted.
Fucking started bagging one of the natives.
That's what you do.
You simulate.
It was like,
oh yeah.
Is that how you make corn?
And that's fantastic.
Show up with a belt.
Buckle on your hat.
I mean,
you think you're not going to get scalped you fucking dope standing there with
your white sox.
Like you're going to do the Billie Jean moonwalk across the fucking plane.
You know,
it's funny.
Did they even dress like that?
Okay.
You know,
how much of of what you think is actual history is actually just what the first
people in Hollywood did when they made movies.
You know what I mean?
And then that just became like,
oh,
this is,
this is what it was.
You know,
like I always do the classic when they talk about the,
uh,
native Americans and playing drums and they always do that.
Danna dunt dunt dunt dunt dunt dunt dunt dunt dunt that was completely made up
by a white guy.
There is no,
there's not one shred of evidence.
In fact,
one of my brothers one time took a tour someplace,
I dunno,
when Arizona and the guy was talking about Indians and native Americans,
sorry,
in percussion,
right.
And uh,
and he was going,
he was showing some of the ways that they would play the drums.
He goes,
they would do it this way.
They do it this way.
They do it that way,
Yada,
Yada.
He goes,
but at no point did they ever go banner [inaudible] killed though.
He crushed.
Got An applause break.
The whole place started laughing because it was a bunch of white people,
I imagine going,
Oh yeah,
that's what we,
it's what we thought they ted.
So anyways,
we've got,
wait,
let me get back to what the fuck I was at solar at the god Damn Alamo,
right.
And,
um,
we started talking to this guy.
He tells the whole fucking story,
man.
Jesus Christ.
It was brutal.
Oh really?
Bill was the massacre there.
Bra.
You know,
you good until you're actually there and you're looking at it and you're
standing on the grounds of it.
Cause what killed me was what they've left of the fort was the inner perimeter.
So where we were standing disrespectfully,
taking silly photos was where a lot of people died.
They just took down the wall that was around the fort.
So what we were looking at was this inner area,
you know,
we're probably the officer's,
yeah.
Took advantage of the women that were there.
Whatever the fuck happened back in the 18 hundreds,
I don't know.
And basically what happens when they showed up was they,
um,
they just fucking killed every guy there.
Even if you gave up,
they just lined you up and shot ya and it's fucked up as that was,
I always think back
to whoever lost the war,
you know,
which I'm going on a limb here saying it was Mexico is,
I have no idea cause they never talked to anyway,
the name of it talked about the fucking,
I don't even know when it happened to be honest with you.
I didn't take the tour.
Like I said,
I was drunk with the cigar.
So,
um,
I mean it wasn't like the Spanish American war.
Did that take place in like the Philippines,
something fucked up.
Like I don't even know what this is fucking hilarious.
Cause every history class I took when I was
just laughing now thinking of you guys rolling your eyes home barriers used to
be embarrassed as an American that yet again,
I'm doing this and this could go out to anybody outside of our borders.
Um,
I should get audited right now for not knowing this shit.
they would always start with 1492.
Columbus sailed the ocean blue and then the pilgrims,
and then they get to the revolutionary war.
Maybe the war of 1812 you'd get up to that and then they stopped and they just
kept going back to it every fucking year.
Just hammering that Shit and ta head Thomas Jefferson,
I could not tell a lie,
completely ignored the genocide of the native Americans.
Completely ignored slavery.
Just ignore it.
All of it.
It's just every fucking year going back to the goddamn powdered wigs,
I fucking hated it.
And then when I finally got to a,
I finally got to high school,
I took this honors history class because I actually liked history and then we
did ancient medieval history.
Holy Shit.
That might have been the most boring stuff.
I just remember the cover of the book had this ancient medieval broken plate on
it.
It almost looks like that stupid,
that dead dish they give women when they win Wimbledon,
which always cracked me up.
You know what I mean?
They give a guy a chalice to drink fucking wine out of,
cause he gets blown by a hooker and a woman wins.
Wimbleton they give her a plate.
Yeah.
Once you go make some biscuits.
This sweetheart,
I'm surprised feminist groups haven't complained.
Like why don't we get a trophy?
Why do we get that deviled egg fucking plate?
You know what I mean?
I Dunno.
Maybe it's considered a plaque.
The fuck do I know?
I thought the Spanish American war happened in the Philippines.
I know we went over to the Philippines at some point we did some sort of damage.
Um,
but could I find it on a map?
Actually I could because I'd been to Singapore.
All right.
It was east of it.
It was east of Singapore.
Um,
if I remember correctly.
Oh yes.
I've,
I've spread my ignorance around the globe.
So anyways,
for there,
and the guy was talking about,
you know how they,
they,
they let the women and children live,
but they completely just killed every guy there.
Even if you surrendered,
even as you were running away from the fourth.
They just shot me in the back and I just was thinking like,
yeah,
man.
I mean that's what she gotta do.
Like whoever that commander was,
Santa Monica,
whatever the fuck his name was,
Santa something or the Santa Cruz,
San Jose.
I think it was a city,
but it was actually a guy who was like his last name.
I think even California had to give it up being like,
you know what?
That mother fucker was going hard.
I know that's not his name and I don't have time to look it up because that
would involve research.
All right,
so you just fucking sit there and your cubicle and you with to this.
How dare you judge me in my ignorance.
It's just sitting there at your job making money,
not doing your fucking job.
How dare you?
Uh,
maybe listening to it in your car.
I don't know what you're doing.
So anyways,
I always think that like,
that's how hard,
like I have an hour.
I think about,
you know,
if I was a native American and I knew,
forget that if you knew,
if they knew,
there we go,
there's the fucking right thrown out.
Right set of pronouns.
Or is it an adverb?
Um,
if they knew what the fuck was going to go down,
can you imagined
that'd be a great series of films just called if they knew right.
And it all about history,
about horrific wrongs that were done about one group of people to another,
you know.
But you know how each one of them would start every little clip of if they knew,
which,
start with a bunch of white people come pulling up in a boat.
Oh,
are these people everybody,
next thing you know,
you were enslaved or you're fucking,
you know,
just getting murdered.
I always thought about if they knew like the native Americans,
what the fuck they were,
they would have,
I swear to God,
they would have all joined forces like in the warriors care.
You right.
And what day would have to do okay is they would have to let everybody come
ashore,
right?
And this is what you do at night.
You slip onto the boats and you'd,
you kill everybody who was on the boat.
So now there's no escape.
All right?
And then you'd have to murder everybody,
men,
women,
children,
all of them.
You'd have to murder all of them.
All right?
Then once all of that was done,
one group of people,
okay,
he's in charge.
You've got to take those bodies and you have to drag those motherfuckers
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of miles inland,
and you've got to bury them when no one's ever going to find them.
All right?
And then meanwhile,
another group of people has to systematically begin dismantling those ships.
All right?
So that the belief would be that they never made it to the shores of America,
right?
No,
that wouldn't work because they just keep sending more in the boats would get
better.
Okay.
I'm just trying to think like how could or the native Americans stopped?
What happened?
It's some point,
well,
I know what you're doing.
You fucking,
you'd have to keep the weapons.
Why would you take apart the boat bill?
You fucking dope.
No,
keep the boat.
All right.
Fuck down.
Let's,
let's back up here.
Still kill everybody on land.
Still drag.
I'm a fucking couple hundred miles inland.
Still Barium.
All right.
Kill everybody on the boat except for like five,
six people.
And then you go,
listen motherfucker,
if you don't teach us how to drive this God damn thing,
all right,
we're going to fucking,
I dunno.
We're going to do something to you that's going to be really painful.
All right?
I know he's somehow you get get them to teach you how to drive the boat.
And once you get the boat right,
you start breaking down.
Uh,
I dunno if a cannon balls and shit.
I don't know how you'd do it.
You just have to keep killing these motherfuckers.
Know.
Maybe the best way to do it is that they don't know.
You know what?
I don't have a fucking solution.
God dammit.
White people are fucking evil.
Huh?
Even me as a white person,
you thinking I could figure out how to stop us.
You know what,
I got to get back to here.
You could if you guys got any suggestions how you could have stopped her,
but it is,
you have to do what they're doing to you,
what they're gonna do to you first.
That's the only way to do it.
You know what I mean?
People come over,
right?
They got a better pistol than you do,
And they think that God thinks what's said,
what they're doing is right and it's fucking over.
There's not going to be,
the only time I have his fucking saw,
the indigenous people survived when a boatload of white people showed up was in
New Zealand.
All right.
And if you saw the,
the,
the people who are indigenous in New Zealand,
every one of them,
I swear to God,
is built like a hall of fame linebacker.
Like,
and I'm not just talking about sa and they look like,
listen,
this dude could change the fucking game and white people pulled up and were just
like,
I,
uh,
you know what?
Let's,
we're going to be here with you and we're going to kind of like share this area.
I mean,
I was only in New Zealand for like three fucking days,
but that's what I was told a while,
drinking in a bar.
I might be wrong,
it might be right.
You know,
hopefully it's wrong because a,
you know,
somebody can count how many words I fucking used incorrectly.
Ah,
Shit.
What if I,
I don't think I've ever done that.
If I haven't counted words,
I don't know,
maybe,
maybe bill or that bill.
You know,
why does everybody have to do what you do get to show,
right?
Go Fuck you.
So
trying to find this,
oh my God,
what the fucking notification thing.
You know something apple with this whole shit where they just have this new
thing where they sync everything and you can't delete the APP and go fuck
yourself.
This is how it's going to be.
Do you guys realize myself included that we are allowing the fucking nerds at
apple to grab us by the back of the neck and shoved her face into dog shit and
just,
we basically gave up some freedoms on this,
this new round with the,
with the,
the iPhone six and they're new.
They're a new Mac book air thing that I bought here.
You know,
as I sit there,
pay in the fucking person who's probably looking at me through that little video
camera.
Right.
I just gave him the finger.
Oh,
you liked that.
I'm a rebel.
You know,
I'm stopping what's going on?
Um,
I don't know.
I just,
I resent the whole thing through my,
my,
my level of being a maniac with control,
being in control freak.
Do you know when I was in San Antonio,
um,
I believe we were at Trinity College.
Like every fucking Gig was just like wake up,
drive four hours,
get in the hotel,
shower,
put your clothes on,
go down,
do the Gig and leave and have to fucking places.
I didn't even know where the hell was that,
but uh,
but the shows are all shows,
Ross.
And I'll tell you right now,
I fucking love Texas and fuck everybody who says all the bad shit about it.
I love those people down there,
man.
Fucking good time.
Um,
and I only had one fucking guy,
only one maniac that really just said something really ugly,
uh,
when I was on stage,
which was,
I thought it was pretty good.
I was doing this thing about Caitlyn Jenner and this guy in the upper deck just
goes,
fuck that.
Fuck it's science experiment or something like that.
I was just like,
wow.
Right.
But you know,
it was great.
I got like 20 emails from people from Houston that we're going,
how embarrassed they were and hoping that I wasn't going to judge Houston like
that.
You know what I mean?
Of course they didn't yell out while that was going on because uh,
when people are dumb to that level,
it's really loud.
I don't know why.
Look at me,
I'm dumb.
I'm really loud,
you know?
But the dumber you get,
the louder you get.
Right.
And then people who know it's bullshit,
they just kind of sit through them.
That's embarrassing.
And I was just going to send an email,
a few people yelled,
shut the fuck up.
I don't know what happened then when I was,
the only thing other than that,
you know,
the way people,
especially out in Hollywood,
they way they look at,
you know,
at the fucking elitists,
goddamn attitudes out of here.
I swear to God,
I thought I was liberal until I came out here.
I cannot fucking stand the politics that are out here.
They are so fuck.
It's literally Fox News to the left.
They areF as fucking ridiculous as anybody you've ever seen on who's that
fucking chick who looks like she needs some iron in her system.
Whatever it is.
She's got like gray skin mean to Rosie's.
Always talk about her.
She sounds like she manages wrestlers.
Like what she says is so over the top,
whatever.
Obviously it's all the way to the right.
But out here in Hollywood you get that to the left.
It's as fucking ridiculous.
And um,
they think that just,
just as right.
Um,
I dunno,
I,
I just,
I do not enjoy political conversation out here is not a fun thing to be involved
in.
You know what I mean?
Don't we just put it that way.
So anyways,
the fuck was I talking about?
Oh,
there you go again,
Bill.
You know,
you go on these fucking tangents and you forget what the hell you're talking
about.
Backing up here,
up here,
where the fuck you were at the Alamo.
Then he did that,
that run through Texas,
Trinity College.
Some about Trinity Coll.
Yeah.
I got a control freak thing.
Right.
So coming out of fucking Trinity College and is what coming out.
It's one of these old school venues where they used to build these venues and
then there was just it,
there was one way in and one way out.
So it was going to be horrific.
Just,
you know,
it reminds me way back in the day when they,
they uh,
when they first made great wards in Mansfield,
Massachusetts,
I don't know what it's called now.
I saw Eddie Murphy there on the raw tour by the way,
had lawn seats.
The weather girls opened up.
It's one of my great,
I saw Stevie Ray Vaughan there.
I saw so many fucking amazing shows there.
I saw Rodney Dangerfield.
Jesus,
I'm old.
Um,
anyways,
I saw Burt Lancaster.
Um,
what was I saying here?
So the big thing about that venue is everybody's excited that they built it
because all these great bands were going there,
but the,
for some fucking reason there,
they had like,
it was like a driveway,
you know.
So over the course of the day,
like 20,000 fucking people would show up driving through this one entrance and
there was already traffic,
but at the end,
all 20,000 tried to get out.
At the same time.
I remember the local radio stations would do these hilarious bits about people,
uh,
still there and not being able to get to work,
you know.
So anyways,
so this was one of these types of venues,
uh,
accepted,
only held like 300 people.
Fuck you.
But still,
you know what I mean?
It was going to be brought to try to get out of this.
So we're running out of there.
I jumped in the car with Z and there's already people,
you know,
running out to try to do what I'm doing.
So it was was sitting there,
I want to bang a right when I get out of the driveway to go exactly where I came
from.
And the cops telling me he sees my directional and he wants me to,
he wants me to go left.
So I'm trying to go right.
And he blows the whistle points right at me and then points to the direction he
wants me to go to.
And I fucking,
what got so mad.
I fucking pointed right at him.
I pointed right back at him and I was like,
fuck you.
You do Shas I yelled at him,
pointing at him.
Fortunately my headlights were on,
it was dark out so he couldn't see it.
And I turned to the left and you know,
it was funny.
It was,
it ended up being the proper way to go out.
it was like a dream.
It was like melted butter.
He was actually doing me a favor,
um,
and not steering me into trouble.
I swear to God,
if you saw the look on his face,
just looking at me like,
dude,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
And the only,
I think redeemable,
quality that I have about my personality is,
uh,
when I do shit like that and somebody looks at me,
I can I at least am a mature enough to be like,
yeah,
I know dude.
High know a fucking moody psychopath.
I know.
You don't even have to say anything.
I see it on your face.
Sino you're right.
Fucking can't get me off.
You got to fucking point and the whistle,
you know.
All right,
so I was wrong.
I'll fuck you guys.
All right,
let's do some advertising for this week,
right?
Oh,
here we go.
I don't know if I've got to send me,
I'm so fucking jet lag.
Demato boat boat beyond Esbe.
I mean,
can I do this in a different,
no,
I can't.
I don't have any musical telling me undies.
Me undies.
No more sweaty balls.
But due to,
to beyond these may or the,
she got a,
by him in the fall,
it's going to get cold your balls or pull up in.
You got your check.
We'll laugh.
Where are your balls?
You got an empty bag.
You're like,
I dunno.
A empty pillow case all.
Yeah,
so get yourself so warm.
Fucking nuts with fucking be on days.
Alright.
Uh,
me undies.
We all know how sexy confidence can be and that confidence comes from being
comfortable.
But how great can you feel your underwear is wrinkling and riding up?
Be on these,
gets it.
And that's why they've created the world's most comfortable underwear,
underwear,
underwear for a daily dose of confidence.
You wear your underwear,
you wear underwear every day.
Unless you Matthew mcconaughey,
that's 365 days a year.
Rain or shine.
You need it to be extraordinary without an insane price.
Tag me on these,
understands this.
They have compassion for your nuts and your wallet simultaneously.
That'd be a great day.
Imagine they'd made underwear on at the same thing you made your wallet out of.
You know what I mean?
Like a nice you.
We get a nice wallet,
you know,
sliding into your back pocket.
Can you imagine that feeling every time you put your underwear on?
It felt the same as a nice quality wallet.
Just slide right into your back pocket.
You know what I mean?
Like you getting ghost by some broad and you turn around,
hey,
how you doing?
She goes,
hey,
you know,
dig.
Maybe you want to come back in a stickier all prick between my tits.
You know,
you know what?
I got to buy more wallets.
That's what's going to,
when you look good,
you feel great.
People.
That's what I'm trying to say here.
It's a cliche because it's true.
Um,
does that make sense?
Technically me.
Andy's understands this and that's why they've designed underwear that makes you
look and feel fantastic.
Please include all of the following points too.
I'm Gunna,
if you wrote it down,
I'm going to fucking say it.
You assholes.
Me undies is made from modal.
It's a fabric that's twice as soft as cotton.
That's twice as soft as whatever underwear you're wearing right now.
Unless you wearing me undies,
me on these soft has a new wallet.
Biondi says tons of colors and styles and the only place to get matching pairs
for men and women.
All right,
that's fucking weird.
And then what are you going to walk down the street doing a tumbling act?
Um,
they even released a new design every month.
I were fill in the blank design,
black stripes,
tied I,
et Cetera.
I wear whatever free ones.
Just send me me undies.
And you know what?
God Damn it.
They feel good about that.
Is that enough of a personal story to keep you guys happy?
Plus we all know that it's a shit way too long.
They get it.
It's comfortable underwear.
Let's get to the end here.
Uh,
plus we all know that paying for shipping sucks.
So me,
and he says,
remove all that from the equation by rolling it into the overall price of the
underwear.
All underwear,
the U S and Canada shipped for free me undies even has a money back guarantee.
If you don't love your first pair,
you get to keep it for free.
If you don't love it,
you'd throw it out.
You're literally has nothing to lose.
Um,
to sweeten the deals,
me on these is offering you 20% off your first order at [inaudible] dot com
slash bird that's a special offer for just my listeners.
Make sure you go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr to get 20% off your first
order and so that we know that we sent you.
All right.
Everybody needs underwear and they're making them all right.
Trunk Club.
Everybody shopping is awful.
See there's a theme here.
Who has the patience for crowded stores or the time to try on 10 pairs of pants
that don't even fit well?
Um,
well it helps if you knew your size,
these randomly grabbing them.
But here's the problem is still you still want to look great,
right?
And with Trunk Club you never have to set foot in a mall again.
Please include all the following points during your read.
I guess other people are skipping all.
Is that an option?
I would've skipped shit a long time ago.
Trunk Club takes the hassles man out of shopping by shipping you a trunk of
clothes that fit perfectly and make you look like 1 million bucks with all the
new fall styles and trunk club.com/burr.
You answer simple questions about your style preferences and size and are
assigned and expert stylist.
They curate clothes from the best premium blimp brands and you approve of what
you like and just like that a trunk arrives on your doorstep filled with
handpicked clothes that are perfect for you.
Try them on,
keep what you like and he's the returns,
the ones that you don't like in their prepaid trunk.
This is not a subscription service.
Everybody you only paid for the clothes you keep from your trunk.
No hidden charges,
just great clothes.
All right,
get started today.
And Trunk Club will style you for free plus free shipping both ways.
You only pay for the clothes you keep to take advantage.
Go to trunk club.com/bar one last time.
That's trunk club.com/ [inaudible] for a trunk filled with clothes you'll love
wearing.
All right.
How many more of these fucking things?
Legal Zoom.
One more.
All right.
On to,
on to ready break.
Alright.
Legalism.
He shouldn't have to choose a random lawyer who charges expensive,
expensive hourly rates.
When you need legal help,
you shouldn't have to do that.
People,
that's all I'm trying to say in that long sentence.
But the legal system is so complicated.
Whether the choice do you have,
when you need help with,
uh,
with your business?
I want to protect your family.
Start with legal zoom.com.
All right.
They make it easy for more than a decade.
They provided a way for regular people like you,
you know,
you put your pants on one leg at a time.
Oh,
vme undies.
Where'd you get those pants?
You pull them out of the trunk from Trunk Club.
Oh,
he's doing fucking advertising.
Callbacks.
Um,
all right.
What did I say?
Or for regular people like you and me to constantly navigate the legal system.
Legal Zooms,
not a law firm.
And that's how they provide such great value
and we don't fix cars,
but we'll give you a cheap fucking diagnostics.
They don't rely on charging you by the hour.
Instead,
you'll get transparent pricing and customer views so you know exactly what
you're getting upfront.
If he need help with incorporation,
LLC,
trademarks,
last,
last wills,
living trusts,
and more legal zooms to smart choice.
They've got the right people on hand to answer your questions if you need legal
advice.
There,
the network of independent attorneys that can provide the straight forward
guidance you need in most states.
Don't let legal hurdles become an excuse.
Go to legals on today,
legalzoom.com today to start building your own future right away to save even
more money and to burn the referral box at checkout.
That's legalzoom.com Promo Code Burr.
Hey,
and,
uh,
what they really should just be talking about is if you die unexpectedly and you
don't have any sort of a will,
like the misery that you're adding to people,
you know,
people start suing each other and all that type of shit,
or you know,
you can get sued because you didn't incorporate yourself.
It's a great way to fucking do it.
Right?
There's the layman terms.
I hope that made sense.
Um,
all right,
let's plow ahead here.
Uh,
I was,
oh,
you know what we went to,
we went to Texas Osu on a Saturday and um,
I gotta tell you,
man,
I,
I've been such a huge fan of the longhorns my whole life,
man.
I just loved,
I just was fucking,
it was a great mascot,
great colors.
I started watching it back when like Jerry Gray was,
um,
one of their big,
all Americans.
I remember you went with the rams.
If I,
if I was correct,
it was just a fan.
And then I thought he was fucking great player.
I missed Earl Campbell,
but,
um,
they were always good.
Texas football was always his shit.
So I always wanted to go and as I mentioned before,
I think I told this last time I will always wanted to go.
And I booked myself with the cap city comedy club when they were playing
Missouri in the afternoon.
I was going to do the show at night and then I was all excited.
I bought tickets,
I was ready to go.
And then when ended up happening was a Texas and Missouri were both for no,
and the flex scheduled moved the game to like eight o'clock at night or seven
o'clock at night.
So not only did I not get to go to the game,
nobody showed up,
nobody showed up to my fucking show.
And I'm so I finally got to go.
And,
um,
I'd like to thank a Dudley from the Dudley and Bob show who hooked me up with,
uh,
with some tickets and south by southwest festival.
They also a,
no,
sorry,
the Moontower festival.
The Moontower festival also hooked me up with tickets.
I ended up with more tickets than I needed and I was actually able to hook up
with some,
some other friends that I've made in Austin.
And uh,
Oh man,
it was great dude.
And I got to thank Luke and all his friends for reaching out to me on Twitter
and I'm,
me and Versie showed up.
We drove up from San Antonio.
Right.
Um,
oh do we have the best fucking time?
Drove up,
got a small breakfast cause we knew this kid Luke was going to be smoking
whatever the fuck he was going to be smoking.
And uh,
we showed up at the tailgate,
you know,
threw some money in.
We've brought some shit that we brought some biscuits in from uh,
the Czech Bakery,
um,
that I,
it's somewhere,
it's near Waco,
Texas.
Whenever you go from the,
if you have a drive Dallas to Austin or vice versa,
when you're on the,
I think it's,
is it the 35 of the 45,
whatever the one that's further left.
Do you looking at a map?
A,
there's a place out there called the,
uh,
the check bakery and just,
I'm,
I'm going to describe it.
Just fucking go in there and get yourself one of the breakfast sandwiches.
It's fucking insane.
Every time I'd drive down,
then you walk in there and you're like,
I'm just going to get one.
And then you walk in and next thing you know you're getting three and splitting
a fourth one with whoever the fuck you're with and you hate yourself afterwards,
but it's delicious.
So I bought a bunch of shit from there,
you know,
some sauerkraut and biscuits and stuff to add to it.
And we showed up and there's two.
Luke was making,
uh,
he was smoking sausage wrapped and chicken wrapped in Bacon.
All right.
And then his side,
he had sweet potatoes with this,
uh,
this butter that he made that had bourbon in it.
And like brown sugar for the sweet potato studio.
It was that butter on the potato.
I was joking when I was eating it,
I was like,
I feel like I'm like getting buzzed and I'm going to have a heart attack at the
same time.
It's one of the greatest things I've ever tasted.
Death.
He actually had a hardy Coleslaw,
has anything worse than the fucking Milky Shit.
It's all water and down spilling into all the good food.
He had,
the hardy kind fucking delicious.
And then they had a peach cobbler that had a peach and cherry in it.
And um,
that it was fucking outstanding.
And I tried to pick a,
you know,
a couple of tips up on smoking meat and everything,
but he actually had a smoker.
So that's completely different than the big green egg.
My problem has been keeping the fire going.
So I actually had a,
a podcast listener reach out who has a big green egg,
was nice enough to send me a long email about some stuff.
So I'm going to try to smoke some ribs on Wednesday,
you know,
I'm just gonna keep doing it until I fucking get it down.
But anyway,
so we met a bunch of people there and first he said the funniest fucking thing
where he was standing there is we're as we're eating the food,
it's like so good where like whisper and going,
oh my God,
dude,
this is fucking unreal.
And verse,
he goes like,
he goes,
dude,
I think people in the south are just inherently better at cookouts or barbecues,
whatever you want.
And we would,
I was joking with one of the guys there was saying like,
because of the fucking we'd grown up in the northeast,
we can only cook out for likes,
you know,
whatever,
five months,
five and a half months out of the year.
And then the rest of the time it's just too Goddamn,
uh,
it's just too goddamn cold or the weather is just too fucking bad.
So every year the south,
the people in the warmer clients just,
they just increased the gap.
Um,
but it was just fucking delicious.
Right.
And,
uh,
so we ended up going to the game and,
I'm rooting for Texas of course.
And uh,
I got to tell you something,
man.
I think I'm a fucking jinx.
I just realized that since I started going to these big college games every
year,
the home team has never won.
Okay.
All right.
The last time it happened,
I went to a game.
I want you to a Georgia bulldog g game in like September with some cupcake game
new,
I can't even remember who the fuck they played.
All right.
But since then,
all right.
This year it was Texas.
Osu texted them,
I'll just name all the teams who they played the first teams.
The whole team.
All right.
Texas,
Osu,
fucking Osu Woods.
All right.
Last year I went to Miami,
Florida state,
Florida state one.
The year before I went to Lsu.
Al?
No,
Lsu.
Uh,
no,
no.
Texas a and M.
Alabama.
Alabama won the year before that I went to Lsu,
And how one again.
And then the year before that I went to the cotton bowl,
which is neutral ground for the longhorns in Oklahoma.
They played the Red River game there.
I went to that game rooted for Texas bed on Texas and Oklahoma smoked him.
So that is one,
two,
three,
four fives at five games.
I'm like,
oh,
in five.
Hmm.
So I got to break the streak.
I'm almost not going to say who the fuck I'm going to next year because,
oh,
I got it.
No,
in a couple of weeks I'm going to Notre Dame,
USC,
Notre Dame's the home team and I am rooting for Notre Dame.
All right,
me and Voz with joking cause verse,
he's been to all those games with me.
I was saying we're like that guy in the mush in a Bronx tale.
So my apology to a all longhorn fans for going to that game and rooting for you
guys.
And uh,
I'd like to some thank you letters from some cowboy fans.
There would always shoe,
dude,
I gotta tell you,
man,
that was such a brutal game to fucking watch and you could feel it.
You could feel it was going to happen to Texas,
won that game like six fucking times.
And then they lost it.
It was unreal,
man.
Every time they,
they,
they could put them away,
they just let them back into the game and that final fucking play.
I don't like making fun of college kids when they don't,
uh,
when they fuck up cause they're not professionals yet.
So I'm not gonna name any names,
but uh,
that last offensive play,
I guess special teams play,
they're literally should have been like Benny Hill music playing.
I,
it just,
all they had to do was kicked the ball away.
They still add to hold him.
You can't break it down to one fucking play.
I mean God knows that pass underneath was there for him all fucking day and they
had no answer for it.
Um,
I don't know.
You'd think if you score too defensive,
touchdowns in a game,
you're defense gave you 14 points,
you think you could win the fucking game.
And they somehow,
in the end they hiked the ball,
the punter dropped the ball and then he's running with the ball.
He goes to kick it,
you know,
goes a mile in the air.
But it only went like two yards before it went out of bounds.
And at that point it looked like it was going to go into overtime.
And I was like,
well,
at least maybe they still have a chance to at least win this game that they
already won six times in overtime.
And then that play happens.
And Lsu got the ball.
And I think they ran it like one time just to position it and then they just
kick the fucking ball.
And,
uh,
I think that was it.
Or maybe they kicked it off with one second left and it was over and it was
fucking brutal.
But,
um,
but like I say,
Longhorn fans are great man.
They weren't like,
uh,
you know,
college fans at different man when Shit's not going well,
they're not as,
at least at the stadium,
they act like class acts.
I didn't hear a lot of,
uh,
screaming about the coach or anything.
So anyway,
so we ended up going back to the tailgate and,
uh,
I forgot to tell you guys,
we had version,
like just out of sheer boredom of driving four hours every fucking day.
Uh,
we were,
uh,
driving down from Dallas to San Antonio,
I think that day.
That was like a four and a half hour drive with the traffic and shit.
And we were trying to write a country song and uh,
we came up with this country song,
uh,
we just say,
all right,
so what do you know,
cause we are the car,
there was a bunch of country station,
so we kept shutting off the radio.
We turn it or we turn the station and which had the sound down go to a new
country station would be like,
all right,
what's this song about?
Is it about her heartache?
A country road or America?
And we just,
that was what we,
that's how we were killing time.
So then just using that formula,
we started writing this country song and we came up with,
we came up with the chorus anyways,
have a country hit country song.
Now granted we can't sink,
but if we got like Travis Tread or somebody,
you know,
like uh,
with some sort of skills,
we think this could be a hit.
So we came up with the sub,
basically went a man,
Rick,
of first,
every other places,
the worst,
ran a B in a foreign
land to live in another,
a country that was basically the chorus.
And we were writing it.
I know it's terrible,
but we'll fuck you were driving four hours in the middle of the Texas.
What are we going to do?
There's nothing to say.
He just walking,
driving endlessly,
right?
So we were coming up,
well guy,
now we could come up with the verses and we just like,
wait,
she's been Paris and he's been to Rome and you been to London.
But that ain't home to me.
I can't remember where we somehow get it.
That's why I say a Marika first.
Every other places worse.
That's where everyone plays his worst,
not the worst first.
He kept getting on it.
So anyways,
so we,
we come out of the game and you know,
we're drunk right as you do.
And uh,
we show back up at the tailgate,
we say goodbye to Luke and all those guys.
And,
uh,
we get our,
of our cigars and we couple of drinks.
So now we're standing there and we don't have a ride back cause we kept it over
and we're both old men.
So neither one of us has the fucking Uber App on our,
uh,
on our phones.
And there's like no taxis left.
So it just sort of stranded at the ut campus,
just laughing,
smoking cigars in his people will walk in,
buy versus starts telling them,
hey,
excuse me,
excuse me.
Uh,
me and my buddy here,
we've got a number one country song on iTunes.
We're really excited about it.
We're just trying to get a little word of mouth going because the numbers are
going down.
Would it be okay if we sing the chorus to you?
Right?
And I'm thinking,
what the fuck is he doing?
But he did it.
So my God,
we got to do it.
So it'd be like groups of like,
you know,
four or five people.
He's ut girls.
Then we were sitting there,
hammered with cigars,
totally committed going Eric the first and immediately they'd have a worried
look on their face heavy.
I love plays is worst rather being a fuck and hers.
And then we get to the end to live in another country and we'd go country.
You had to bring your chin down to your chest and then you brought it up.
That was,
it was either that part would make us laugh or the FEC and hers.
Um,
and we bombed with it,
man.
These girls would just walking away,
shaking their heads or just laughing.
And uh,
then there was this one dude walked by men.
This guy was fucking hilarious.
He came walking by,
he's by himself,
he's Latino too,
right?
Big Guy.
And he's like,
ah,
man.
He goes,
don't listen to that.
And he takes his headphones off and we start singing it and he immediately gets
a smirk on his face and then we start laughing.
And then all three,
it was just great.
All three of us for laughing.
And he couldn't tell if he was serious.
He just knew it was fucking stupid.
Um,
I was probably one of my favorite times of the trip.
And then finally this absolute fucking sweetheart stopped and she was so nice
and we sang the whole thing.
I actually felt bad about cursing.
That's how nice she was.
And then like as we were singing it,
like three times she went,
oh,
oh.
Like it was nice.
She was so nice.
And the other thing she just goes like,
oh no,
that was good.
It was good.
You know,
we found out,
I go,
what do you do for a living?
You know it,
I swear to God she was a social worker,
so he just was a big hearted,
encouraging person.
She was so like fucking such as sweetheart.
We were like standing on the other side of like this little stone wall.
So we wouldn't freak out.
You know,
a couple of guys standing in a wooded area going,
hey ladies,
ladies is kind of creepy at night.
So we were on the other side of a wall to get a little bit of a barrier so we
could get people to actually stop versus he actually walked around and she was
such a sweetheart.
He walked around to the other side of the wall.
And gave her a hug.
Um,
anyway,
so,
so that's what we did,
you know that was Texas and then I went on to a Marika first.
It's going to be in your head.
I'm telling you somebody out there with some talent,
man.
Trying to think of some of the other lyrics we came up with.
Okay.
Or something like I like,
okay.
Pickup trucks in pony tails,
shooting fuzzy queries.
No shooting.
Little Curtis with fuzzy tails
sitting in a tree for covering in day or your run.
I can't remember how it goes.
We read every thing we would come up with.
Uh,
whatever we were killing a fucking drive.
What do you want from it?
But if you don't,
if you guys want to flush that thing out,
I don't keep up.
I what?
I know what I'm talking about anymore.
Um,
can you tell him also reading right now so easily.
I get fucking distracted.
So have I talked to NFL football yet?
But did you do to do the bad at that?
Good.
Where did I take the day?
Shocking.
Shocking,
shocking.
New England patriots.
I caught the end of the game.
Uh,
miss the entire fucking game.
As always.
I miss the whole fucking gay.
I was flying up to Toronto,
so,
uh,
I was hilarious when I landed.
I get my,
uh,
the guy picking me up,
right.
I jump in,
I'm going to go on.
I can't go,
hey man,
I didn't realize it was sun ago.
Did you guys get an NFL football up here?
And he was like,
what?
I go NFL football,
you know,
like patriots,
cowboys,
Steelers,
you get American football up here and he's looking at me in a rear view mirror
and he just goes,
no,
I just start laughing.
I'm like,
God man,
I forget it.
But when I got to my hotel room,
they had it on.
I actually had the buffalo bills network cause I was in Toronto,
which was really cool seeing that local shows and that type of thing and seeing
them all wanting to,
you know,
rebound from the heartache and loss to,
uh,
to the Patriots and Jesus Christ.
Did they ever,
oh my God,
they absolutely fucking raped the dolphins yesterday and,
um,
as did the patriots with the Jaguars.
So,
uh,
like I said,
man,
we play them again.
I'm still calling it man.
I still think that that could go a,
I dunno for some reason,
I just think if,
if you have a good defense and then if you play a team two times in a year,
you usually split.
It would really be great to beat Rex Ryan twice.
So then you don't have to listen to them talk shit again.
But that's what makes some great though.
The fact that even though he has a mediocre team,
I'm still worried about beating him as like,
we gotta beat this guy so he doesn't talk a bunch of Shit.
Um,
he's fucking great.
He's like a one man,
a promotional team there.
But,
um,
I didn't watch many other games.
I,
uh,
by then I had to go out and,
um,
go do my show.
I caught a little bit of the late game,
uh,
the Sunday night game,
or did I,
I can't even fucking remember,
but I wish I had watched the cowboy's game that looked like that was a hell of a
game.
Uh,
but I pretty much missed everything.
So,
uh,
I think I got to go in the NFL network and try to watch him shit.
But I'm definitely going to be watching,
um,
the Monday night game tonight and I ain't going out.
I'm not doing shit.
I'm wiped out.
ACDC is playing tonight at Dodger Stadium and,
uh,
if I get a second wind,
I'm going to go out there and I know what you guys are think bill,
how the fuck can you not go at least go get some nosebleed seats for that.
And I've just been on the road for 15 fucking days,
drinking,
smoking cigars and all that Shit and uh,
I'm completely fucking white out.
I've seen them a bunch of times and I know that this isn't the last fucking
tour.
You know what it is,
dude,
I fucked up.
I didn't get tickets and I hate myself right now because I'm not going and it's
going to crush me that they're going to play and I'm going to miss.
And I'm terrified that this is the last time they're going to go.
And I know that I'm going to regret that.
I'm not going to go tonight cause I'm fucking wiped out there.
That's the truth.
All right.
Before you jump all over me.
All right,
let's get into some of the,
uh,
questions here for this week.
Uh,
rugby World Cup.
You know,
everybody keeps talking to me about this in Japan winning.
I really feel like I missed out on something,
man.
It sounded amazing.
Bay Bill,
a deer billion burn person.
How they hell are you?
I'm good cause he wrote me to uh,
anyway,
uh,
I don't know if it's getting a much time on sports center,
but the Rugby World Cup is on in England at the moment.
The USA are playing Scotland as I write this and winning,
although probably not for long.
Uh,
just Jesus Christ.
What do they make per game
to fucking knock their brains out though?
You,
I've talked about the USA team.
Um,
I'm a huge fucking fan of rugby and uh,
I got to tell you two sports that I kind of make fun of,
that I'm actually starting to get into.
I find myself trying to fight it,
but if it comes on TV,
I'm watching it.
Soccer and golf,
they sucking me in.
Uh,
just wondering what you know and,
or think about the game.
I think it'd be right up your alley.
Big Guys beating the hell out of each other to move a ball to the other end of
the pitch.
There are rules,
but that,
uh,
that's the guts of it.
I like to hear your thoughts.
Thanks for doing your job.
Uh,
I benefit from it.
Oh,
thank you.
Um,
any rates to go fuck yourself.
I absolutely love watching rugby when I'm in Europe or if I'm in a country that
supports it.
The,
I don't know what it is.
Just the announcers.
You can hear it in their voice.
It means something.
You hear the crowd.
It's just,
um,
it's just something about being over there.
I mean,
I,
I would become the biggest fucking,
I'm going to keep calling it soccer so American listeners don't get confused
with the football thing.
Um,
and please can somebody for the love of God not ask me again why American
football is called football.
You barely kick it with your foot.
I've told you why a long time ago we figured out that your football is fucking
excrutiatingly boring.
And then if you picked it up and added some violence to it,
you know what I mean?
We do everything on 10
you know,
just fucking with you.
No.
When I'm over in England,
like in those premier league games,
come on,
I really get into it.
It's fucking great.
How can you not?
Okay.
From in England,
it's fucking cold out.
I'm in a pub,
I'm drinking a beer and everybody's going nuts and they were riveted watching
the shit.
It is impossible not to get sucked into it.
And I have to tell you,
I am fascinated by people who don't give a fuck about sports.
Fascinated and envious of like,
God,
what do you do with all that free time?
Yeah,
I'll kill a whole fucking Sunday,
but it up,
but at that
right,
but the end of the fucking day,
I'm sitting there like Eddie Murphy in the clumps.
Remember the outtake,
what?
He had the ice cream porn out of his fucking,
at least what are you going to coming out of his bottom lip?
That's what the fuck I look like by the end of the day.
And I do it again the next Sunday if I'm not flying to Toronto.
Um,
I think rugby is the shit.
I think Australian rules,
football is the shit.
And I think soccer,
football,
let me be respectful to the rest of the world.
I think all of it's the shit.
All of it's great man.
Sports are awesome.
I don't have a problem with any of it.
And if it's violent,
it's fucking maniacs running around.
My only real complaint because I really do think soccer is a beautiful sport.
Uh,
my complaint is,
is the diving,
and I actually at this point prefer women's soccer because they go down and they
get right back up.
You know that fucking men about it.
All right friend fucking up.
Dear Bill,
my 26 year old friend in my opinion,
is in deep with a lady.
Uh,
she's around 30 with three kids.
Oh Jesus.
And is recently divorced.
Good Lord Dude.
Okay.
Is he wearing like a weighted vest just walking around too to add even more
difficulty to his fucking day.
Ah,
they've only been together for a few months,
but he's already got car seats and shit in his cars to tote these heathens
around.
He's not what I would call a ladies man.
So anytime he gets into a relationship,
he falls in love quick and you know what the world needs dopes too.
You can't help him.
He said,
my concern is that he's going to end up playing daddy to three kids that aren't
his for the rest of his life,
which in my opinion,
like a God damn nightmare.
While those kids also need a father,
he's doing something really admirable.
But if he's doing it for the right fucking reason,
it's admirable.
If he's just a fucking dope with low self esteem,
you got to pull him out of this man.
You know,
you got to walk up to those fuck his fucking car and punch out the side windows
like the terminator did to the windshield and you throw those car seats over the
fucking guardrail.
All right.
No,
I'm not saying to do that.
All right.
Anyways,
um,
my question is do I talk to the kid and let them know that the,
that all of his friends think he's going down the wrong path here.
He's the kind of guy who doesn't handle those talks very well.
So I could see him going ballistic.
Should I let them know or should I let him crash and burn one way or the other
with this?
I realized watching this train work for the foreseeable future makes me a shitty
friend,
but as a,
but as guys,
these conversations suck Dick,
uh,
listen to,
you know,
he needs to grow up,
man.
If he can't handle constructive criticism,
if you just say,
look,
I'm just looking out for you.
All right,
you're going to go from being a single man with all the options in the world to
a,
a committed man with three kids instantly.
MMM,
it's,
this is what you want to,
I dunno.
Maybe that'll drive them further into it.
I mean,
I,
and I also think that a lot of reasons why,
like he doesn't do well with those conversations is because if he is somebody
that just kind of gets into something and gets trapped in something and doesn't
know how to express himself,
that usually adds to a lot of anger.
How do I know this?
Because I've been that guy.
Um,
I was
okay,
very like,
uh,
withdrawn.
If anybody said hello to me,
then I was friends with them and I,
there was no asking what I wanted,
what I needed,
what I was looking for.
I didn't figure that out to very late in life,
which is probably why I didn't get married till I was 45,
but at least I wasn't dumb enough to get a
yeah.
To,
to,
uh,
get married to someone that I,
I wasn't,
I always knew enough to be like,
all right,
I got to get out of this.
But I,
I was not good at that at all.
And that was a very angry guy.
Um,
I dunno,
I don't know what his deal is or his psychological fucking backgrounds.
You've got an overbearing father.
I have no fucking idea.
I'm not doctor Phil or Johnny Weissmuller here.
Wherever the fuck I'm supposed to use as the rest of the reference.
But um,
okay.
You know,
why does Johnny Weissmuller sound like a doctor?
He's the actor who played Tarzan,
by the way.
Um,
anyways.
All right,
asking.
So I would just say,
uh,
you know what dude,
dude,
fuck his moodiness.
Fucking baby.
Just tell him what you think.
You know,
just sit down and just say,
listen man,
as a friend,
I have to say my piece on this thing.
All right?
Uh,
I just want to make sure that you,
you know what you're doing here because you are taking on an unbelievable
responsibility and you are effectively ending your youth immediately dealing
with this woman and these three fucking kids then mean it's one thing to get
married,
have a kid,
you know,
fall in love,
get married,
right?
And then have a kid and you deal with that.
Then you have another kid,
you deal with that you're just going,
Bam,
married kids.
Three kids got to pick them up to daycare and whatever.
It's like,
yeah,
you don't need to do that.
And I know there's a lot of people out there with divorced,
with kids.
That probably annoys me right now.
But you know what?
I don't give a fuck.
This isn't about you.
This is about a man.
It was 26 years old who?
He's got the world at his fucking feet,
all right?
If this is what he wants,
it fits what he wants.
She got to support it.
But if he's being a fucking dope,
say your piece so you don't have to feel bad.
All right?
And then later when he talks to you about it and he's going to have to say like,
you know what dude,
you are right.
And He'd be like,
you know what?
It's alright.
You can crash on my couch.
All right.
Asking older girl out.
Hey Billy,
fat,
tits.
Hey,
fuck you man.
I'm in shape now.
I just wanted to say a,
you've encouraged me to lose 30 times,
30 pounds now since you began,
uh,
I did as well,
but still have a few months ago to this fucking great.
It's great,
man.
Good for you.
Keep it going.
Uh,
anyway.
Anyway,
to the question,
I'm 23 and the girl I'm thinking about asking out is 34.
I feel like this may be one,
maybe the one if she's perhaps said yes because we clicked so perfectly when we
are together and when does age become a factor?
Well,
she's 34.
If she wants to have kids,
I would think that age is going to be affected pretty soon.
Uh,
or should I just move on and try to find someone around my age?
By the way,
a great drama did checkout is Marco Miniman.
Uh,
yeah,
I've definitely seen all his stuff.
That guy is insane.
He goes,
I saw him a while back at it.
Joe Satriani concent and thought it was the greatest drumming I've ever seen.
Anyway,
keep up the podcast and go fuck yourself.
Yeah,
that's the kind of guy he can like do a drum solo to like,
you can give a,
an excerpt of this paragraph and the way my voice goes up and down.
He would voice it on the drums.
He's one of those guys,
man.
He's like,
he's like from another planet.
Um,
quick call,
by the way.
Ah,
you're 23 and she's 34.
Uh,
my gut says,
yeah,
don't do it.
Don't do it.
23,
dude,
you're in the prime of your fucking life.
I would get a woman who was my fucking,
if somebody 34,
we're probably going to get married pretty soon.
You're 23.
You don't need that Shit,
right?
Get yourself a fucking Philly 23 years old,
dude,
you're drafted in the first round and you're going to trade down to the six
round.
Fuck that.
And I know there's a lot of women that are going to listen to me and say that
that's bullshit,
but fuck you.
Because women do that to other women.
You guys give each other advice like that on your show.
So,
well,
when am I going to do,
because women's issues,
I'm going to give a 23 year old guy,
bad advice,
dude.
Fuck that.
She's 11 fucking years old and then you,
she's going to be in a completely different place.
Women are way more mature than guys.
Are you going to be like a fucking kid?
All right.
And she's going to be so fucking advanced as far as you know,
haven't been in relationships too.
You're going to give up so much goddamn territory.
My Gut says don't fucking do it.
They'll fucking do that,
dude.
Don't do that.
All right.
When you're 43 and you still P90x and she's going to be 54 going through
menopause.
All right.
I'm just saying this is harsh,
but you know what?
I wouldn't be a fucking,
uh,
I wouldn't be honest if I wouldn't be,
if I wasn't saying this all right now if you keep,
but I'm not saying it's wrong.
I'm just saying.
All right.
My Gut says,
when I look at those numbers,
you know,
we don't have a deal here.
This isn't a good fucking trade.
Um,
but having said that,
good luck to you.
All right.
Uh,
shit jokes.
All right.
What's up?
Their sizzle Nutso.
Ah,
yeah.
Uh,
been listening to your podcast around four years now and you often make a
negative reference reference to shit jokes.
As a kid,
I always laughed at Shit and fart jokes.
And now in my thirties I still think they are funny.
Uh,
why are they frowned upon?
And do you have any good ones?
Is it just you or does the entire industry not take the jokes as being credible?
Also,
you suck at the Internet.
Last week you gave your mom podcast email address when telling people where to
send their questions and you said it's bill@thecapitalmcapitalmpodcast.com email
addresses in web website addresses are not case sensitive chief,
thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Okay.
You,
you know,
it's fucking hilarious how young people think that computers are cool.
I just don't understand what,
what is so awesome about these fucking things?
It just,
what?
You know what it is,
what you give up in your free time and in money and that this a fucking camera
and God knows who's on the other end of it and you have to like put a piece of
tape over it.
You know what I mean?
Who knows?
If you fucking laptops open and you're their fucking,
you're a woman.
And there's some Guy Watch it,
you know,
Eh,
jerking off somewhere,
another part of the country.
It's just,
it's fucking bizarre.
That's the forest.
One of the funniest thing,
email addresses and website address or not case sensitive chief.
Did you flip you little fucking hair after you type that you cunt?
Um,
all right.
Shit jokes and fart jokes.
Uh,
they're considered sophomores,
bodily fluid jokes and that type of thing.
I don't completely write them off.
It's just me just being self deprecating,
just joking around.
Oh,
what you look at that,
would you look at that?
And I got a text message.
I really needed know that while I'm doing a podcast,
you fucking apple conch,
um,
put the mute button on at least.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
so that's what it looked at.
I have to be honest with you,
man.
I love this shit joke.
I love a Fart joke.
If it's a good one,
you know,
if somebody is just up there,
so I'm fucking wiping my ass and club,
you know,
not saying anything.
Then like,
I think what happened was with the oversaturation of comics during the eighties
comedy boom.
Um,
okay.
You know,
there was,
there was material that just everybody was doing.
It was just easy.
Laughs cause I think maybe that's what it is,
is if you do a shit joke,
it's gone.
It's going to get a laugh.
There's no way.
There's just,
it's practically impossible to do with shit joke and not get a laugh to get us
to do a fart joke and not get a laugh.
So,
um,
it's considered like low hanging fruit.
Having said that,
I don't think there's anything wrong with low hanging fruit.
Like,
you know,
I'm a big fan of fucking movies and I love a movie that's trying to do something
different.
But if there's one that's just,
you know,
one of those tough guy movies and just write down the pike,
nothing fucking new,
but it's done well.
And their attitude is not that we're doing something different here that just
like,
we're just going to make one of these movies.
I don't have a fucking problem with it.
So,
um,
you know,
if a comics on stage doing a shit joke,
if it's funny,
I don't give a fuck if it's easy.
I don't give a shit if it's fucking funny.
It's funny.
So,
uh,
but the reason why I use it as a reference like shit,
Dick Jokes is a,
it's just sort of,
um,
just a self deprecating thing.
That's all.
That's all I'm trying to do.
All right,
gang spill.
If you were in a gang,
what would your surrounding theme,
B I e motorcycles,
gangs involve writing.
Would you be in a comedy gang?
Uh,
New England sports fan gang?
definitely more like the latter.
It would definitely be more like fantasy football,
nerd gang.
I'm,
I'm all right if you,
on one end of the spectrum is absolute,
a total rebels,
motorcycle gangs.
And then the other side is fantasy football.
I am somewhere between those way more towards the fantasy football thing.
I am a,
I ain't no tough guy,
right?
I'm not trying to go to jail.
I don't need any of that shit.
And you know what,
I don't want to do anything.
You know,
I don't be involved in violence.
I just don't,
they want to explore that part of me and I don't want it done to me.
Um,
to fuck gang.
Would I be good?
I Dunno.
I don't think I could be in a gang that actually called itself a gang unless it
was making fun of itself.
How about enthusiast?
Oh God,
they all of that is too hard.
How about I go to a hobby?
Hobby town places.
You know what this whole question is giving me Deuce chills.
Congratulations to your dues shells.
I always give credit to the opiate Anthony show.
Uh,
the late great opion Anthony show.
Um,
when I fucking say that cause that's where I learned the term.
I never heard anybody else say it.
Was it.
Oop.
Who came up with that?
I have no idea.
I got a call or an opiate.
Jimmy.
Oh cheats.
You see a stamps.com.
Everybody your to do list can seem out of control so much to do.
So little time,
but there's only one thing you can,
but there is one thing you can check off your to do lists going to the post
office.
Thanks to stamps.com with stamps.com you can buy and print official US postage
right from your own computer.
And printer stamps.com we'll send you a digital scale.
Automatically calculate the exact postage you need for any letter or package,
any class of male.
You'll never waste valuable time going to the post office again to everything
right from your desk with stamps.com print the postage you need,
put it on your letter or a package.
Then just hand it to your mail carrier and you're done.
I use stamps.com to send out all my posters.
Anything that I'm selling,
any march after a shell.
Um,
I use stamps.com and I'm a moron.
I can figure it out.
So can you right now use my last name bur bur for this,
this special offer,
four week trial plus a $110 bonus offer that includes the d,
The digital scale.
Jesus almost fell down there and up to $55 free postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com enter
[inaudible].
All right everybody.
And as always,
if you'd like to donate,
go to Amazon,
go to a bill.com.
She'd like to donate to this podcast.
Uh,
click on the march page,
click on the Amazon link.
That'll take you there.
I get credit for driving traffic there and whatever,
uh,
anything you buy there,
they kicked me a little dough for,
uh,
you know,
for driving traffic there.
And then,
um,
then I send my,
you know,
I sent 10% of that to a charity that seems like it's on the level right now.
I'm doing the Saint Jude Hospital.
I always say what charities,
just to make sure if they are a scam,
people can let me know cause I don't know how to figure out whether they are or
not.
I know people said,
Oh,
here's a website and this says whether they are or not.
And I,
I,
you know,
is this guy I mentioned,
I'm not good at the Internet and I'll fucking lose it.
So,
uh,
I've been doing that.
And then I also want to donate to,
if I,
if it's possible to donate to a Andre Agassi's,
uh,
school in Vegas after reading this book.
It just seemed like a,
that's pretty much an air tight thing over there.
Just seems like an amazing thing that he's doing and everybody else over there.
So anyways,
that is the podcast here for this week.
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
Uh,
thank you from the bottom,
my heart,
everybody that came out,
uh,
all the way to Texas.
Thank you.
Everybody who listened to,
uh,
me and Paul Versey sing our country,
hit America first
and then everybody who came out and Toronto man,
unbelievable shows up there.
And uh,
it made me sad to only be in all of those cities only for one night because,
uh,
you know,
I used to play the clubs before I did the one nighters and it was always fun.
There was all these,
there's all these places,
food places and all these places that I like to go.
So,
um,
I definitely got to get back to Toronto during hockey season.
You know,
the hotel where I stayed at,
we went by Jesus.
What Day is it?
The most and center.
I can't fuck members of where the habs play on a piss off maple leaf fence.
But I went by and I was immediately remembered this story of me and Versie when
we went to a game there.
It had the best time.
It was so cool to bring versus either,
cause he's not a hockey guy.
And then you know,
anytime you bring somebody to see hockey live,
they freak the fuck out.
And to actually see it in Canada,
an original six team,
what that ridiculous fucking fan base.
All right.
There's no way Canadian fans would be showing up like hab fence.
It will,
you know,
in the drought that the Toronto has the effect that,
that that's the hardest fucking ticket to get fucking practically impossible to
get a maple leaf ticket.
Right.
Um,
even when I compliment the fucking may police,
I still have to trash the Canadians.
I just have to do it.
It's,
it's fucking habitual with me.
So anyways,
we would,
we'd gone to the game when we came out.
It was just,
it was absolutely fucking like,
you know,
minus 10 degrees and there was wind and we were trying to get a cab and
everybody was,
any cabinet became available,
people were jumping in.
And I remember standing out with there with Versie and it was so fucking cold.
I remember we just,
we're just laughing.
At first we were Carson our brains out.
And then at one point we just did the wind blew again and it was just so cold.
We just,
it was like,
I think we're just going to fucking die out here.
Um,
but I just,
I have so many great fucking memories of,
uh,
that Canadian tour that we did.
So,
um,
as much fun as it wants to do those two shows,
it's suck to only be there for one night.
So I definitely got to get back.
And,
um,
I did get to spend quite a lot of time in Austin.
I had one day off that I spent in Austin,
and then the next day,
uh,
we also,
we went to the ut game.
We had a great fucking time.
And,
um,
what do we do?
Dallas?
And Houston,
the Houston.
I mean,
I went to Houston so quick,
I didn't get to go to south pug guitars.
That's how fast,
uh,
we went through town.
But,
uh,
hopefully the next time through a law,
spread it out a little bit more.
And,
um,
once again,
thank you to everybody,
came out to my shows and see all you guys in the Midwest,
um,
later on this month.
And once again,
I'll put the links up for the,
um,
for the benefit shows I'm doing this weekend in Washington DC.
All right,
that's the podcast for this week.
I'll check it.
Oh,
you on Thursday a go fuck yourself.
If not,
I'll talk to you next Monday.